hello everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio at San Diego Comic-Con
2023 I am beyond thrilled to be here
with Gareth Edwards talking about what I
can say is one of my most anticipated
movies of 2023 the Creator I mean I
obviously haven't seen the movie but my
God that trailer is incredible who cut
that trailer that is a beautifully
edited piece
um thank you well I can't take credit
for it it was Disney
so the whole Disney marketing machine
um it was probably an editor obviously I
don't know their name basically this
stuff kind of gets presented to you as
like
when it's close to being ready and you
sort of see a few different posters you
see some of the trailers and
and it's just you know as a group
decision we sort of hone in on something
and then you're allowed to change a
couple of shots if it bothers you or
whatever they're very inclusive and uh
yeah I was I was worried it was the
wrong choice because I was like I just
got paranoid about it you know like
you're so close to it I love it I don't
know I was worried like Aerosmith I love
Aerosmith I love that song Dream On but
I was just kind of paranoid that it was
that it didn't I don't know somehow
because it's not in the movie you know
and then I was completely wrong because
everyone seemed to have a good reaction
having a huge reaction and Steve Tyler
owes me a Lamborghini now
he owes you a Lamborghini the money they
got for that trailer so I'll take a
Ferrari okay that's it that seems like
an even trade right there
um I'm a big believer that that trailers
are also made by artists and that is one
in particular that I've seen in recent
years that really does feel like I could
feel the craftsmanship behind it and I
appreciate it genuinely not to get
sidetracked
um there is a way trailers seem to
function that I really like I'm obsessed
with where
they can tell stories and get
storytelling done so quick and they
don't get locked into this thing of like
wide shot you know over your shoulder
over their shoulder conversation it's
all like abstract dream like stuff that
just jumps around and you can follow it
and I like I in my mind I'm like I just
want to do a whole movie like that you
know I mean like but would it would it
get too much would it just be overload I
don't know I like the sound of a
challenge like that I hope you do it one
day now this challenge now from here so
we'll have to Circle back when you make
that movie I'll be here to do the
interview Steve Tyler has some more
songs that he'll say yeah really it'll
be good more more cars too
um talking about the Creator and the
evolution of the idea I am curious I
love asking this question because I love
hearing about how things change along
the way what would you say is the
biggest difference between draft one of
this screenplay and what you wound up
with in the finished feature oh wow
that's a good question
um
what's the biggest difference draft one
I'm trying to remember
um
I don't think it's the it might not be
the biggest difference is the thing I
remember
is there's antagonists in the movie in
my first draft there was
um
Joshua who's played by John David was
basically on this sort of Odyssey across
this futuristic war zone
um with this child and being pursued by
um
one side
and I guess in the next draft
is pursued by both sides now
oh interesting okay which is way better
I don't know why I didn't think of that
in the first place that was a note it
definitely sounds like a richer more
well-layered story right there I like
that what about in terms of how the
conversation about AI evolved from draft
one to finish film did you ever find any
of that kind of you know conversations
and the warnings about what AI could do
to the world influencing how you tackle
that material in the film no it was like
um I mean basically the movie was always
like the world is divided in two half
the world is banned AI they hate it it's
wrong it caused some real big problems
and the other half of the movies
embraced it carried on developing it to
the point where it's now human-like and
so it's kind of a East versus West kind
of situation at the start and at the
very beginning it was like but why would
you ban it you know I mean like there
was genuinely every single reaction to
the screenplay was why would anyone ban
AI it's like this amazing thing and like
and so they had to kind of invent
scenario where you might reject it right
and weirdly now the way things are going
it's like the default setting is Ban it
right and it's a strange reaction that
we've all had
to this technology it's like this freaky
mirror that hang on how come this
this is there's no one home but yet it
seems so real would you describe the
film as a cautionary tale regarding AI
or is it more so the film heavily
leaning into presenting AI as the other
it is is it's presenting ai's the other
but it ends up
we don't fully well no spoilers right of
course not it's it's I like films that
are gray that are not like black and
white and
and where you sort of experience the
full conversation
of both sides and and it's up to you how
you end up feeling about it at the end I
appreciate that it means I get an
enjoyable experience in the theater but
it weighs heavily on my mind there yeah
we found when we did test screenings and
stuff when we showed people
everybody needed some time like you kind
of want to switch the lights on and go
okay what did you think and have it and
everybody needed
to think about it and it was like it was
quite it was really interesting because
you kind of hope for that in a weird way
but
it was it was quite a predictable
response was was
it was a lot you know what I mean and
and and we were used to it we'd seen it
so many times and like trying to find
the right condensed Rhythm of the movie
and and I like that idea that it's
something that bounces around afterwards
like you're not sure how you feel about
it kind of thing and it's something that
I imagine gets gets like richer and
richer with every single re-watch where
it leaves the door open for your
feelings about it and your
interpretation of it to change which is
very exciting it definitely gets richer
with every re-watch where you pay like
20 bucks to go see it again in the
theater I I recommend
at least 10 viewings if you can do it
fair enough fair enough all right to get
into a little bit of the World building
here so John David's character has to go
to New Asia to locate this AI are you
able to tease what the rest of the world
looks like is is like nothing in this
movie in terms of how the world is set
up like our reality is now I mean try to
avoid like this big kind of political
geopolitical lesson at the start of the
film
so you only really kind of hear about
things you need to you know know about
um New Age you're being one of them
um it's left to the audience what's some
other aspects of the world is going on
um but new age is basically this region
of Southeast Asia and Japan where
the borders of because of this war
against the eye
um the borders have sort of dissolved
and different people from different
countries and AI from different areas
will come together to kind of like
kind of fight the West
um who are trying to like eradicate AI
from the world just curious did you
pinpoint a specific year that the movie
takes place in I did I did and I've made
a mistake because I should have picked
2024.
but I picked 2017 because I didn't want
to make the mistake Kubrick made of like
2000 and you know one not being true so
I was like I'm gonna pick something way
Downstream and it was like oh God it's
probably next year
that's I mean that's like the
conversation we keep having now there's
this is very random but there's one
thing I keep remembering from when I was
a kid going to sleep away camp and they
always used to make a joke that like in
the future it will be like uh it'll be
uh like a camp trip for that particular
group to the moon and like we got like
now there's like people that are buying
tickets to go to the moon and it's just
something that we never used to think
was going to be a reality it was just a
joke that we used to say and now it's
happening yeah there's certain things if
you'd said like okay predict out of all
these things jet packs you know go going
to the Moon you know whatever what are
the things that you think science
fiction is going to achieve in your
lifetime I didn't really have ai as like
a definite you know
I thought we might land on Mars again
maybe before I died you know but this
was like
eons away and then suddenly and even the
experts said it like they thought it was
like 30 years away and it and it and it
turned out when they started kind of
mimicking the way the human brain works
and creating these like neuron networks
um it's actually quite straightforward
and and some this magical thing happens
where it's kind of like unless you
religious it's just a bunch of switches
and if you mimic it guess what happened
you know it kind of seems like it's
alive and and the big question is I
think the things they have right now are
probably not you know they're these
large language model stuff like chat GPT
and that
um but it's coming like and they all the
people working on it are like
you just Chuck enough
resources at this stuff like make it big
enough give it enough uh training and
they there's you know everyone's
expectation is that we'll have something
akin to us
in a few years or so
I don't know why this just came to mind
and I don't know if you've thought this
through in terms of your back story but
the thing that kicked in this world that
the movie takes place and the thing that
kicked off the creation of robots in
general and this AI that ultimately led
to this war that the movie is exploring
are those things that exist in like our
real world reality now it was so it's a
nuclear bomb right
um detonated and
you know in the same way that
I don't want to pick a famous make of
electric car but you know how a car
might self-driving car might crash and
it's through some random it's nothing
malicious it's just a random accidental
thing with the algorithm like a simple
error and it results like in military
hardware like that could cause
horrific consequences and and so it's
like it's one of those and it's all it's
going to take is one of those moments
like where a plane just falls out the
sky or something where everyone goes
okay we can't do this anymore like this
is too risky
like we need to figure this out and and
so it's off the back of that kind of
event
that that AI gets banned and you can
imagine like the idea was we don't have
time in the movie to get into this but
but the idea that like things would come
with little stickers and low you know
little logos that say like AI free you
know like don't worry kind of thing and
it creates this kind of
um movement against AI which we sort of
seeing like we shot scenes in Thailand
with people with protest signs for and
against the eye
thinking this is like kind of absurd and
now like I live very near the studios
and we drive past and and that's exactly
it's exactly what's happening the thing
about
does feel like something that could be
very much in the realm of possibility in
the near future that's that's kind of
blowing my mind right now
I didn't want to end this conversation
without talking about your production
process here because I'm fascinated by
the idea that you went to a whole bunch
of different countries and then you did
a whole lot of the work in post to
really build out this kind of futuristic
scenario here I am really curious
because a hot topic of conversation
right now is is overspending on Films
is that a more cost effective way to
make a movie like this and is that
something that is specific to this story
or is or are those techniques that could
benefit other Productions in the future
uh I think it's gonna it's not unique to
this film whatsoever the sort of ways we
did stuff and
um
it's like what happens on a movie is at
some point you get sat down and I say
you can't do this why not because we
don't have enough money
I thought we had
x hundred million dollars and
um and they say we do but like we can't
afford to do that and you go hang on
explain this come on hang on this makes
no sense and someone will go through
line by line
and any and you'll go but why are we
spending on it why is this and it's like
it's like there's so much
I think like hemorrhaging of money well
basically what I put it down to the very
simple analogy is is if you had a dollar
bill the way filmmaking works is they
buy a five dollar case to protect that
dollar bill because they don't want to
lose the dollar right and now they look
at it and go oh hang on that's six
dollars we need to buy a ten dollar
uh you know like cabinet to put this in
to protect our six dollar investment oh
wait a minute that's 16 oh we need to
and they basically spend more and more
and more to protect it and protect it
and protect it if you just say at the
very beginning you know what we're going
to spend one dollar We're Not Gonna
protect it if we lose it we've lost the
dollar and we'll just spend another
dollar doing it again and and that's
kind of was the philosophy of like let's
spend as little as possible let's like
let's go out on a limb if something
doesn't if something fails doesn't work
we'll we'll we'll just do it again right
we'll figure our way around it and we
had a mantra on the with the the
producer in the film which is
I think our movie ended up turning it
it's a lot of money it's 80 million
dollars it's a lot of money and the
Mantra was like
no and never we never want to hear I
never want to hear anyone ever say we
can't afford to do that we only have 80
million dollars right and so if no one's
allowed to say that
you can kind of do anything like you can
do anything he's just choosing what
you're not going to do you know I feel I
feel like more more folks out there
should have that weighing heavier on
their mind than they do often I lie I
have another behind the scenes questions
because I really wanted to ask about
working with two cinematographers on
this can you walk us through why that
became necessary on this project and
also because like Greg is one of the
best of the best and I just saw Oren's
last feature film and he just seems like
a name on the rise in that particular
field that excites me yeah so Greg's
like
um one of the few people in the world I
would trust like to to like give a
camera to and say you shoot it you know
try and get this kind of shot and just
hand it over
um he's got an amazing eye amazing
everything
um the whole world seems to know that
now and and so we started building up to
this movie and this other movie called
uh June or June 2 was sort of on them
no it's a small Indie little sci-fi
thing it's doing the festivals
um he he was like obviously in a
position that he had to do that and so I
was like secretly praying that they
weren't gonna clash and obviously at
some point that started to be like this
is they're gonna Clash
um and so it was like Greg okay let's
scour the world who's who's the best
newcomer out there and after a lot of
conversations Greg was like there's this
guy or in software and I need to take a
look at his work and I he's kind of a
little uh Protege of mine and I've been
kind of working with him on other stuff
and so I looked at Aaron's work it was
really strong the chat with iron really
liked him and so basically there's this
transition that happened and Greg
carried on remotely
um but Oren like picked up the Reigns
and um and I I mean I'm really excited
for people to see the film because
one of the main takeaway feelings is who
did that you know I mean like and so I
think Orange
I mean I'd like to be orange agent right
now
because they can go you know with Steve
Tyler they can go buy Ferrari for me I
think
I like that did you see fixation yeah
it's stunning I don't even like cars I
don't know what I'm saying this it is
something else I'm very excited to see
his work my last question for you
because I'm always fascinated about
choosing the right title for a movie and
I know you changed from true love to the
Creator so can you kind of walk us
through uh determining that true love
had to go and the Creator was the best
way to you know essentially introduce
people to the idea because first and
foremost they see title before they
experience anything else yeah I mean you
have lots you have a working title when
you make a film and the most important
day is the first day you're going to
announce it to the world stick it on a
post there any of that stuff and you
just got to decide before then like is
that the title and the whole time I was
making this my feeling was
when you watch the movie like people who
have seen it go I see why you wanted to
call it true love right but ahead of
going to see it if you just go to some
random person in the street and go do
you want to see a film called true love
they're like I'm not really into
rom-coms you know you go that's not that
it's not that and I and I sort of didn't
want to spend my life having everyone
come up to me going oh my God I just I
just saw um true love or whatever it was
and I didn't realize it was like that
kind of movie and so Disney with all
their
Common Sense were like basically like we
we feel a great title would be the
Creator and it's in the movie A lot and
it made a lot of sense and
I'm very glad we changed it now
um it's strange when you you have a
child who's identified as one name and
then suddenly like you have to get used
to calling it someone else I'm just over
that now like now I find myself
accidentally saying the Creator all the
time but for a while it was true love
um but
they both when you see the movie it
makes sense it's like they called um
Blade Runner was dangerous days and
there's a lot of like working titles for
films that when you hear them you're
like okay yeah I mean like I'm sure that
would have worked yeah but it may it may
it makes sense but there's reasons that
you change it and the reason you change
it is to make sure that you have the
widest possible audience for your film
that like again it looks incredible I
love that trailer as always I have all
the faith in the world in you you've got
an excellent team you're working with an
early congratulations I cannot wait to
see it thank you thank you thanks